[Music]
thank you very much you know a funny
thing I was in the supermarket the other
day and I saw this little boy he'd
gotten separated from his mother and the
manager came by and said what's your
name little boy Mohammed and you lost
your mother yes can you tell us what she
looks like I don't have any idea
and that sums up the clash of
civilizations that we are embroiled in
today it is too markedly different views
of the world to markedly different views
of society and they are actively
clashing now as some of my recent
experiences illustrate as some of you
may know I spoke at Stanford University
in Palo Alto California on Tuesday night
and I'll tell you before I spoke It was
as if Adolphe Hitler were coming to
campus and the Stanford daily paper the
student paper was in an absolute uproar
they were absolutely shocked
flabbergasted that the College
Republicans and the young America's
Foundation would have the gall the
temerity to bring someone in who
demonizes and dehumanizes an entire
community of people and that's what they
said now dehumanizing an entire
community of people if you step back and
think well what exactly do I do I have
written about how jihad terrorists used
the Koran to justify violence and to
make recruits among Muslims who are
peaceful if the Muslim community at
Stanford was actually threatened by that
then they are actually saying or
implying that they're on the side of the
terrorists because if they're not then
why would they oppose anybody who is
exposing the motivating ideology of the
terrorists I'll tell you something else
a few months before I arrived at
Stanford they had a speaker there named
Bob Barr Judy who is the son of Marwan
Barghouti who is in prison for
engineering the murder of five Israeli
civilians he spoke on campus no problem
no attack articles leading up to his
appearance no protests everything was
fine
they also had Mads Gilbert who's very
aptly named Mads
and he is a Swedish spokesman for
something-or-other who has actually said
that 9/11 well the Americans had it
coming and they deserved it he spoke at
Stanford no problem but when I spoke at
Stanford there were actual Stanford
administrators Nancy Howe who is the
Dean of Student Affairs or something or
other and her assistant whose name is
Sneha Naik and they were both at the
event they engineered it so that the
room was packed about an eighty to
ninety percent with people who had no
intention of listening and they actually
kept out members of the College
Republicans the sponsoring group about
five minutes in those eighty to ninety
percent all stood up and walked out and
then how an Ike the the Stanford Dean's
prevented anybody else from coming in
even though there was a large group of
people who wanted to be in and a whole
hall full of empty seats they wouldn't
let them in now why was that because on
this terrible villain
I am an islamaphobe now what is an
islamaphobe as a matter of fact I was
speaking at ya young America's
Foundation one of their conferences not
long ago and I asked that question and
it was this high school girl in the
front row she said someone who knows too
much about Islam and I thought you know
you got a point really that kind of sums
it up but I've actually written this new
book and yes this is an advertisement
confessions of an Islamophobe that is
really about this very strange
phenomenon that if actual supporters of
jihad terrorism go to a campus they're
celebrated as heroes but if a foe of
jihad terrorism goes to a campus then
he's a terrible villain and the actual
administration of the college itself
makes sure that as few people as
possible hear what is being said now
this is an extraordinary situation and
the contrast between what sanity or
reality would dictate and the situation
that we have prevailing on the college
campuses
is extraordinary and that actually can
best be illustrated by a story that I
tell in this book about my own
background how it is that I became such
a hated and notorious Islamophobe and I
can tell you it all started back in the
Ottoman Empire I wasn't actually there
my grandparents tamati awesome Paco's
and Maria Christophe Agius were born in
says MMus in smear smear nough in what
is now the Republic of Turkey and was
then the Ottoman Empire and they grew up
there when I knew them they were they
were very old and sweet and I would ask
them they were kind of exotic you know
with their house full of strange
pictures and strange odors and strange
things all sorts of exotica it was
foreign you know it was unlike what I
was used to or at least the way I was
growing up when I would visit them I
would ask them where are you from
we're from Turkey why are you here we
were exiled
why are you exiled and they would clam
up whether they didn't want to tell me
or they weren't really clear on it
themselves in any case I was fascinated
my grandmother actually was like Barack
Obama one of the two people in the world
who say that the sound of the Mazzini
calling the Muslims to prayer is the
most beautiful sound in the world and
she said it was wonderful when we were
growing up it was beautiful to hear that
and we were friends with the Muslims and
everything was great well then why were
you exiled I started to research I
started to try to find out and what I
found out ultimately was that they were
exiled because they were offered the
choice as the Ottoman Empire was
declining the the the subject people in
it were offered the choice to convert to
Islam or be exiled and this is because
they were considered Kufa Harby infidels
at war with Islam because you have the
Empire that is based on Islamic law just
like Isis today or Saudi Arabia or
or Somalia or Sudan or Pakistan or
Afghanistan it's based on Islamic law in
Islamic law if you're not a Muslim you
have to submit to the rule of Islam you
cannot insult Islam you cannot say
anything critical of Islam you have to
pay the tax the jizya you have to submit
to various kinds of discrimination can't
hold authority over Muslims and all this
and if you do that they will leave you
alone within the bounds of all that
discrimination and harassment that is
built into the system but if you rebel
then you are likely to be killed and
your can lawfully be killed in those
days do you remember if you have read
any history the Ottoman Empire was known
as the sick man of Europe it was
collapsing and the non-muslim people in
Turkey particularly the Armenians and
the Greeks wanted independent states the
Greeks wanted to unite with Greece in
Europe that had won independence from
the Ottomans in 1821 and the Armenians
wanted their own independent state so
they were infidels at war with Islam and
they could be killed or exiled it was a
matter of fact when the Armenians were
exiled that the conditions were so poor
as they were on their way out of Turkey
that the million-and-a-half of them were
killed and this is the Armenian Genocide
a similar thing happened with the Greeks
and the West which is much less known
and the casualty count was not as high
now anyway
this is the thing my grandparents got
here and they were very happy to be here
and they knew what they had come through
and my grandfather when he moved to New
York City and he started the Greek diner
that is kind of I think it was a
requirement he was very proud to become
an American citizen and he was always
careful to vote and he knew the value of
a free society in ways that I think a
lot of people who grow up in a free
society don't necessarily know because
they don't have anything to compare it
to you see my grandfather's experience
was steeped in his own reality in the
nature of the real world now you
contrast that to the Stanford students
who stood up and walked out
the other day these are all people who
were born in the United States probably
mostly born around what now 1995 or 98
or something and so they've missed
everything and they grew up in this
affluent society and they're told that
the West is a terrible oppressor that
the United States is based on racism and
hatred and oppression and that they have
to stand with the marginalized people of
the world and that the Muslims are among
the marginalized people of the world and
so to speak critically about Islamic
terrorism is a terrible thing that
further marginalizes the Muslims of the
world and therefore they have to stand
against it now this is not reality this
is just plain fantasy people talk about
Islamophobia and actually in reality if
you look at FBI hate crime statistics
the hate crimes that are committed
against Muslims are far less common than
hate crimes against Jews hate crimes
against blacks not only that but the
idea that to analyze the motivating
ideology of jihad terrorism is the same
thing as some Mogga hat-wearing
vigilante tearing off some poor Muslim
as a jab that in itself is a
propagandistic conflation of two things
that are actually quite distinct nobody
is in favor of vigilante attacks on
innocent Muslims insofar as they
genuinely occur but the idea that to
analyze these things properly is the
same thing it's just more fantasy now
when you have people who are more
attached to fantasy than to reality then
they will act the way that they did in
Stanford the other night because they
really have no clue about what the real
world is like and so I did try to bring
them a dose of reality and one of the
things I said actually in the very few
minutes before they all left
was I want to thank the most
marginalized community at Stanford
University the College Republicans
and that's absolutely true because if
you think about it if you followed the
story or if you follow the story like
what n was just talking about or any
story of any conservative who tries to
speak on a college campus it's the same
thing that not only is the speaker
defamed and vilified but also the
sponsoring students and the dinner that
night before the event I said to all of
them I really have to commend your
courage because I get to leave tomorrow
and you have to stay here and they have
to stay in that environment where they
are hectored and bullied and mocked and
ridiculed not just by their fellow
students but by the administration and
where they are told that they are
transgressing the bounds of what is
polite discourse and decent society by
bringing in speakers who are hateful
racist bigoted Islamophobes and so you
have the administration saying we have
to stand up for the marginalized
students and their marginalizing the
Republicans far more than the Muslims on
any campus or any other group on campus
has ever been marginalized what we're
talking about really is the larger war
that is the war that we face today and
that is a war between fantasy and
reality the left is clinging to various
fantasies and demonizing and vilifying
anybody who has done refuses to hold to
these fantasies you know though I mean
the whole idea of so many things that
are staples of the leftist discourse
that the war on poverty that if we tax
people very highly and put a lot of
people on welfare they won't be poor
anymore
and they will join the society and
become productive members thereof even
while we are incentivizing them not to
work it's ridiculous it's fantasy based
and it's the same thing as in this case
that when we have 30,000 jihad terror
attacks around the world since 9/11
and we have an international
organization that is still very much
alive although it must be noted that
President Trump has rolled it up and
deprived it of its base in Iraq and
Syria that is Isis we have Isis coming
to the United States vowing to kill
American civilians and then saying that
especially since they've been deprived
of their base that they'll be returning
home I don't think they should be
allowed in but European governments and
all too many American officials believe
well they're American citizens they have
to be allowed back in can you imagine
the thought experiment about that just
for a moment imagine if there were a
bunch of British Nazis in 1940 and they
left Britain and went to Germany to
fight against the British and then in
1944 when things are going bad they went
back to Britain and they said we're
British citizens let us back in do you
think the British would have let him
back in they might have let him back in
to prison but they wouldn't let him back
in to walk the streets but yet the
latest estimates are that they're at
least 400 returning jihadis from Isis
who were walking on the streets in the
Britain because they're citizens so you
have them coming back and they're gonna
kill Europeans
they're gonna kill Americans they have
vowed to do so they have done so and
they will continue to do so and you have
an international organization of other
groups that have the same motives and
the same goals you also have very
powerful states that are dedicated to
the same goals the Islamic Republic of
Iran is one of the two chief sponsors of
terrorism in the world today they have
Hezbollah working with drug cartels
right across the Mexican border and why
are they there they're not there just
for that they're there ultimately to
cross the border and to wreak havoc here
and in the face of all this and so much
more
Stanford is upset about an Islamophobe
somebody who is speaking out against all
that it's a topsy-turvy world you
remember the White Queen from Alice in
Wonderland who could believe five
impossible things before breakfast they
got nothing on the students at Stanford
the idea of Islamophobia was actually a
propaganda construct that was developed
in the 1990s by the International
Institute of Islamic thought which is a
Muslim Brotherhood Saudi funded
organization and the International
Institute of Islamic thought had a
meeting where they were specifically
discussing ways that they could attach a
stigma to resisting Jihad terror and
they came up with this term Islamophobia
it's based on the idea of homophobia and
the idea is that if you oppose jihad
terror there's something wrong with you
and it is some sort of an irrational
hatred probably racist based on simply
disliking Muslims and wanting to cause
them harm this we know because actually
somebody who was there at the meeting a
member of the triple-i T the
International Institute of Islamic
thought abdullah ahmed mohammed he
actually spilled the beans later he had
a change of heart and he said that the
whole construct of Islamophobia is a
thought crushing device designed to
intimidate people now how well does it
work we'll look at what happened at
Stanford and that's no isolated incident
remember at San Bernardino in December
sec on December 2nd 2015 - Muslim Syed
Rizwan Farook and tashfeen Malik married
couple they went to a Christmas party
and they murdered 15 people whilst
screaming Allahu Akbar they were
affiliated with Isis they did it in
response to the Islamic states call for
the murders of American civilians and
after that their neighbors were
interviewed when the neighbors said yeah
you know we saw a lot of suspicious
things we did we saw strange looking
people unsavory looking types going in
and out of their house at all hours and
trucks pulling up and going out at all
hours strange goings-on
well did you report them oh no we didn't
want to be racist
that's how the whole that's how Islam a
phobia works it's it's something that
goes back years you remember Nidal Malik
Hasan the Fort Hood shooter an American
Army Major and he November 4th 2009
started screaming llahu akbar and
murdered 13 Americans at Fort Hood now
he had been known he was on the radar
for a long time
as a matter of fact he had given Grand
Rounds he was an Army psychiatrist and
Grand Rounds is when one of the experts
in a field gives a talk to the other
experts in the field about the latest
developments in the field so all the
army psychiatrists are gathered round
and Nidal Malik Hasan has his turn to
give Grand Rounds and instead of
speaking about the latest developments
in psychiatry he speaks about jihad and
he explains to the audience all about
how Muslims must not fight against other
Muslims and so if there are Muslims in
the military and they are sent to Muslim
countries it is perfectly reasonable for
them to strike out and kill American
soldiers and he said many other things
in this vein such that he was reported
by a lot of the other psychiatrists they
went to the superiors and they said this
guy's scaring the daylights out of us
we're afraid he's going to go jihad one
day the army psychiatrists whoever their
superiors were they did nothing and it
was even worse Nidal Malik Hasan was in
touch with Anwar Awlaki you know Anwar
Awlaki
he was the Imam who was celebrated right
after 9/11 as a beacon of moderation and
what Islam can be in the future by the
New York Times and there's a wonderful
documentary about Mohammed on PBS you
can find this on YouTube and it's not a
wonderful documentary in that it says
anything that's true but you can't
expect that from PBS and in it at one
point they're profiling this
congressional staffer who is a Muslim
and so they're following him around
during his day and at one point he goes
to Capitol Hill to the Muslim prayers at
Capitol Hill and
the camera goes around the room and if
you follow these guys you know you see
Nihad Awad and Ibrahim Hooper of the
Council on american-islamic relations
and Randall Royer who was also with care
at that time and then served 15 years in
prison for terror plotting and you see
other prominent Muslims in the room and
then the camera pans back and who's the
Imam Anwar al-awlaki right on Capitol
Hill on wall a key of course was a jihad
terror mastermind he was not only in
touch with Hassan he was in touch with
the underwear bomber humar Farouk
Abdulmutallab who tried to blow up a
plane on Christmas Day 2009 over Detroit
with the bombs set off in his underwear
and Jerry Lee Lewis has a song about
that and in any case he was also in
touch with 9/11 hijackers and with other
jihad plotters so here is Nidal Hasan
and he's in touch with Anwar al-awlaki
and the army knows about it and an FBI
agent who's tracking this correspondence
calls his superiors he was in San Diego
he calls his superiors in Washington and
he says this guy is in touch with this
jihad terror mastermind and he's an Army
Major and the FBI said we're not
interested and the correspondence kept
up he wrote again the FBI said not
interested and this happened a few times
finally the the agent in San Diego was
so disturbed he went to Washington
himself he went to the offices of the
higher-ups in the FBI and he set out the
evidence about his song and you know
what they said to him they said if we
kept track of every Muslim in the
military who was in touch with terror
leaders we would do nothing else oh okay
well then never mind and that it would
look bad for them to take action against
Hassan because there would be bad
consequences in the media now that's
where it gets to it can you imagine if
when the people who were hearing Hassan
and were disturbed if when they went to
their superiors if Hassan had been
disciplined or fired or court-martialed
or whatever what would have happened can
you see it CNN Islamophobia in the
military Army Major shares his faith
speaks about Islam and is demoted or
whatever and they would be ruined
careers flashing before their eyes I'm
sure that's what kept them from saying
anything and that's the power of the
Islamic obeah idea so in a certain sense
the people that stand for the right
Islamophobia is a much bigger problem
than jihad terrorism but they're not
right in the way that they think they
think that poor innocent Muslims are
being harassed and persecuted and
victimized on some large scale in the
United States that's a lot of hogwash
they think that to analyze the
motivating ideology behind Jihad terror
is some sort of Islamophobic offense
that threatens Muslims who are peaceful
that to is hogwash but they are right in
one sense Islamophobia is a bigger
problem than jihad terror because it's
the chief enabler of jihad terror what
did Stanford University do when it got
me shut down
it was enabling the people who I am
opposing
it's not hard if it is a terrible
heinous thing that makes you on par with
Hitler walking onto campus to oppose
jihad terror then nobody's going to
oppose jihad terror and they can say oh
it's all about racism or dehumanizing or
all that nonsense but in reality all I
do is oppose jihad terror and oppose the
oppression of women and gay
and non-muslims that is under Sharia
oppose Islamic anti-semitism and so on
so if all that is wrong if all that is
hateful if all that is out of bounds
then all those things can go on
unchecked because nobody will have the
guts to stop them to stand up and say
yes I'm gonna be racist and bigoted
Islamophobic and oppose you and so
Stanford is enabling jihad terror and of
course Stanford is just one school this
is happening at universities all over
the country but they are bi in fostering
this Islamophobia narrative that is
intrinsically fantasy based they are
aiding and abetting the forces that are
vowing to destroy us and destroy our
freedoms now the only problem that they
have is that they are at war with
reality and reality always wins the
reason why propaganda is propaganda why
it has to be dimmed at us all the time
why we always have to hear that Islam is
a religion of peace why it's constantly
repeated after every Jihad attack then
there ten articles in The New York Times
and CNN and the Washington Post and
MSNBC all telling us how Islam is peace
why do they have to keep doing that
because it's false and a lie can only be
gotten over by constant repetition
otherwise you're gonna believe your lyin
eyes instead of what they keep telling
you and so they have to keep repeating
it so that reality doesn't break through
but reality always does break through
and this is why ultimately in the final
analysis things are in a very state of
the deep state of crisis in the United
States and we do have a shot to win this
but the biggest weapon that we have on
our side is not Trump and it is not
certainly the Republican Party and it is
not anything but the fact that we are
the real reality based community and
that every morning when the news
headlines come in they confirm that what
we are saying about the world is true
and they show insofar as they are at all
telling the truth themselves which is of
course by no means assured then
we know that our worldview will be
confirmed if the Stanford students were
to pay attention they would see jihad
attacks regularly in the United States
and around the world and people being
killed if they were to pay attention
they would see there aren't any people
being killed by right-wing Islamophobes
and Muslims are not being demonized and
marginalized in the United States and
the thing is some of them are going to
pay attention because you can't keep
reality out forever it's just not
possible
and so I want to conclude with that
exactly that that we have a tremendous
reason to hope we have to stand firm and
we have to keep going no matter what
names they throw at us and no matter
what they how what they come up with
next to try to stop us and to block us
but ultimately as long as we Hugh to the
truth and have reality on our side we
cannot lose thank you very much
thank you very much
if we have five minutes left for a
couple of questions and we're gonna take
a quick break so a couple questions here
yes thank you for your presentation
thank you a few months ago at one of our
organizations we had dr. Zuhdi Jasser I
asked him these questions because
several of us in this audience have
taken courses in the core in at FAU
several years ago and I asked him how do
you get around the 124 we had to notate
this in the course anti Christian and
Jewish statements in today's quorum and
how dr. Jasser do you get around the
three series that say if you don't
convert in 30 days you die
or you become a so called dimming
allowed to live as you just espouse so
my question is how does a modern
American Muslim go to a mosque and read
this when he then brought on his answer
he said well if you're a thief it says
you should cut off your arm we don't
think of that anymore we're more
Americanized that and said we will sever
a friendship do you believe that's how
they think in a mosque today no I can
assure you that they don't as a matter
of fact you know the I started with a
joke I'll end with one you know what
they call a first-time offender in Saudi
Arabia lefty and
the amputation for theft is in the Quran
chapter 5 verse 38 it has not been
abrogated it has not been reinterpreted
and it is enforced wherever Islamic law
is enforced Islamic law is not enforced
in the United States so of course they
don't cut off the hands for theft
because they'd get arrested but if you
have Sharia in the United States you
will have amputation for theft
the fact is Zuni jasser may be a
beautiful guide but his Islam has no
basis in Islamic tradition or theology
there has never been an Islam like his
there has never been anything any basis
of in the Quran for what he's saying
there has never been an Islamic sect
that teaches Judaism if it if I were you
some of you were Christians okay if I
were if I were to come to you and say
yeah I'm a Christian and I believe in
the Trinity the Father the Son and
Mickey Mouse and I'm the real Christian
and those people who say the father and
the Son and the Holy Spirit they're out
to lunch and I repudiate what they say
I'm the a genuine Christian and imagine
a world in which the people who were
saying Father Son and Holy Spirit were
committing acts of violence in the name
of Christianity
and then I and everybody nobody wanted
to condemn the whole thing as a whole so
I became a media star and every TV show
would feature me and I would say the
Trinity is the father in the Son and
Mickey Mouse and that's the true
Christianity and people who had not read
the New Testament and had no idea of
Christianity they would buy it because
they don't know and they would think oh
good most Christians are like Kim so we
don't have to worry about those violent
ones well actually that's a made-up
Christianity and zooty's is a made-up
private Islam that he has I'm glad that
he's going around denouncing care and
all that that's great but to pretend
that he represents any kind of broad
mainstream in Islam
simply has no basis in fact it's also
misleading when people see him and they
say oh most Muslims must be like this
guy we got nothing to worry about
okay one more question anybody
this will be our last question thank you
I'm just wondering if you have any
insight into the way the Las Vegas
Massacre is being handled the Las Vegas
Massacre is extraordinarily curious for
one thing the official story has changed
so often I can't keep track first we
heard the guy committed suicide then we
hear he didn't first we hear that that
was the security guard coming down the
hall and he shot him and then he shot
himself now it turns out he shot the
security guard at a completely different
time and so on and so on so in the first
place the authorities themselves have
deliberately sown confusion about this
whether through their own incompetence
or whether by some active plan but they
have made it so that nobody can figure
out what's really going on that's one
thing the other thing is of course the
Islamic state Isis has claimed credit
for it many people made fun of them and
said Isis they claimed credit for the
weather they claimed credit for
everything not actually true there is
actually no snow record of them ever
claiming credit for something that
didn't turn out to be theirs there were
two main incidents one was the shooting
down of the Egyptian the Russian
airliner in Egypt and they said that was
theirs and all the authorities in the
world said no no no there they're lying
and they had nothing to do with it they
could not have had anything to do with
it and then a few weeks later Isis
produced proof that they had done it and
another one was a shooting incidentally
in a Filipino casino and here again they
said that was our guy and this was an
isis operation and if this was
immediately dismissed and a few months
later the terror experts in the
philippines starts saying yep it looks
like it was an isis operation now in
this case they said it was an isis
operation universally dismissed maybe
this is the first time they've lied
about being responsible for an attack
but you notice there were recent
shootings by non-muslims in various
areas and they didn't claim credit for
the
they don't go around claiming credit for
everything now I'm not saying maybe this
is the first time that they are claiming
credit for something they're not
responsible for but if they did that
consider that they have a following and
their following has to believe in them
and they've taken a lot of hits lately
because of all their losses in Iraq and
Syria and so if they are shown up to be
lying about this they're gonna lose
among their own followers I think the
jury is still out about that I don't
think that the ISIS claim can be
discounted immediately but what is even
of greater concern is that whether it's
Isis or not something is being covered
up here in a very large way by the
authorities and that this is yet another
sign of how much the swamp needs to be
drained thank you very much